dans quelques jours Versailles va
accueillir le Salon du livre d'histoire
ça se passera le weekend du 25 et du 26
novembre c'est un événement qui a été
fondé il y a 16 ans par le président de
l'association Histoire de lire et par le
maire de versaill qui est avec nous
François deasier bonjour bonjour Alors
c'est un événement devenu important pour
la ville ce salon du livre d'histoire je
suppose ah tout à fait euh c'est un
événement qu'on souhaitait avec Étienne
de mon Téti faire et dès que j'étais
lumère nous l'avons mis en place parce
que il correspond à l'image de
Versailles Versailles c'est une ville
histoire avec son château et aussi ses
très beaux quartiers historique et
naturellement j'avais envie et tien de
montti bien évidemment c'est est
directeur de figure littéraire comme
vous savez c'est de développer la
lecture parce que la lecture c'est la
base de la culture pour tous et à
Versailles il y a une tradition de
lecture qui est importante mais on
voulait encore l'amplifier voilà donc
c'est conjugison ces deux volontés c'est
à la fois parler de l'histoire que notre
ville incarne et également développer la
lecture l'objectif c'est de rendre
l'histoire et la lecture plus accessible
à un large public absolument et on voit
le livre historique s'est beaucoup
développé ces dernières années il y a un
lectorat fidèle qui apprécie pouvoir à
la fois le plaisir de la lecture et puis
quoi de plus passionnant que de
découvrir des biographies et de
découvrir une époque à travers la
lecture et alors d'année en année ce
salon s'agrandit cette année pour cette
16e édition il y a environ
190 auteurs c'est un moment de rencontre
d'échange pour eux oui Absolum on a
beaucoup développé aussi à côté
évidemment la présence des auteurs et de
la signature puisque traditionnellement
dans les salons du livre vous avez les
auteurs qui sont là et qui mett des
dédicaces et on a d'ailleurs choisi de
faire ce salon quelques jours avant Noël
parce que c'est une occasion beau cadeau
voilà mais on l'a développé alors
d'abord vers les enfants il y a donc la
présence d'une tante une grande tente
dédiée aux enfants qui devant la ville
de Versailles devant la mairie de
Versailles c'est symbolique et alors
quels seront les auteurs les plus connus
qui seront présents alors il y aura
beaucoup d'auteurs connus mais alors
vous avez plusieurs catégories vous avez
les les auteurs qui sont par exemple des
grands hommes politiques donc Alain Jupé
sera là Alain Jupé j'aurai l'occasion
d'ailleurs ça devient un rendez-vous un
peu pour lui oui oui oui oui bien sûr
chaque année on revoit des grands
politiques qui aiment écrire ou où on
revoit surtout des historiens bien sûr
parce que le principe c'est les livres
qui ont été publiés dans l'année or vous
avez des historiens comme Petitfils
également qui sont assez incroyables ils
arrivent à faire un livre tous les 2 ans
et et pourtant des livres qui sont
extrêmement fouillés très riches sur le
plan historique puis vous avez aussi des
journalistes cette année vous avez m
cota qui a été une journaliste essentiel
de la 5e République qui a lit écrit un
livre sur la 5e République et vous avez
aussi bien sûr des artistes euh je pense
à Laurent Deutch par exemple qui est
bien souvent ou des gens qui ont des
profils atypiques comme Christophe
Barbier qui est
entre le grand euh spécialiste politique
grand journaliste spécialiste politique
et également amateur le fou de théâtre
qui écrit tantôt un livre sur le théâtre
tantôt un livre sur l'histoire politique
voilà après vous avez les nouveautés de
l'année et ça quelles sont-elles alors
ces nouveautés les nouveautés de l'année
c'est s alors j'ai pas le programme
détaillé en tête mais par exemple à
Manou qui est tout même très grande
figure de aujourd'hui la littérature qui
sera là parce que il vient d'écrire un
ouvrage alors il y a 6 ans vous avez
lancé le prix youtubeur d'histoire oui
quels sont les vidéos qui ont été
sélectionnées cette année est-ce que
vous pouvez voilà nous expliquer un
petit peu ce qu'est ce prix youtubeur de
l'histoire alors le prix youtubeur de
l'histoire moi-même j'aiété le premier
surpris à voir ce qui existéit
aujourd'hui sur
Youtube autour des initiatives prises
par donc des passionnés d' histoires qui
utilisent Youtube pour mettre des
émissions alors généralement assez
courtes mais qui sont remarquablement
bien faites et donc il y a une
communauté très importante qui s'est
créé autour des youtubeurs passionnés
d'histoire et alors je moi j'étais je
suis pas un spécialiste de YouTube hein
je vous dis très honnêtement
et donc j'ai plutôt eu le plaisir de la
découverte j'aurais encore le plaisir de
la découverte ou des gens qui ont des
initiatives passionnantes dans ce
domaine et souvent avec beaucoup
d'humour d'ailleurs et une façon de
présenter l'histoire qui permet
d'étendre les publics et c'est ça aussi
la volonté ça permet d'attirer les
jeunes d'attirer les jeunes d'attirer un
autre public voilà et et c'est notre
souci que ça soit visis des jeunes il y
a aussi des opérations qui sont dans les
lycées à l'occasion de ce festival il y
a il y aura deux présentations de film
aussi voyez qu'on parle de l'histoire un
peu sous différents supports mais
toujours tout même avec ce primat
accordé au livre parce que le livre
c'est la conservation c'est la mémoire
collective en fait et la nouveauté cette
année c'est la dictée de Versailles
pourquoi mettre en place une dictée pour
le Salon du livre soir al parce que nous
avons ici une association qui depuis
longtemps fait si vous voulez des dictés
très bien organisé euh et qui a du
succès et là on a décidé si vous voulez
on a proposé à cette assoation de
conjuguer le jour
donc de la dicté qu's avaient l'habitude
d'organiser avec la manifestation
histoire de lire donc il y a plusieurs
rendez-vous qui vont aussi se succéder
il va y avoir des conférences des débats
mais aussi la projection de deux films
vous en avez un petit peu parlé il va y
avoir Napoléon le mardi 21 novembre et
Jeanne duarry jeudi 23 novembre là aussi
c'est important de projeter des films
d'histoire là c'est des avant-premières
donc c'est l'occasion si vouz de même
que ce festival histoire de lire met en
avant les dernières productions
littéraires sur le thème de l'histoire
et bien là puisqu'il y a deux films qui
sont des films de grands publics qui
viennent de sortir qui vont sortir sur
l'histoire c'était l'occasion de pouvoir
les diffuser et bien merci beaucoup
François deier d'avoir répondu à nos
questions alors si vous êtes intéressé
notez-le bien dans vos agendas le Salon
du livre d'histoire c'est le weekend du
25 et 26 novembre à l'Hôtel de Ville de
Versailles à la préfecture des ivelines
à l'Hôtel du Département et à l'Hôtel Du
Barry le billet est au prix de 2 € et il
est valable 2 jours vous retrouverez le
programme complet sur le site internet
histoiredelire.fr